hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and today we're going to be
looking at another harper's bazaar
what i in a day review of lil yachty now
let's first talk about my sponsor so i
know i talk about squarespace
a lot over here but i do get so many
questions about
how to quickly scale an online business
and i do think that it really does start
with a website or blog
so squarespace is an all-in-one platform
whether you're looking to build a
website
blog online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics
they have some awesome extensions for
e-commerce that allow you to promote
products and streamline bookkeeping
collect
payments and donations and link up your
social media accounts so that
everything works together seamlessly i
say the best
use of your time is in your business not
in putting together a complicated site
so if you're looking to start up a new
business or passion project this year
and you need a website to really get
started check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
slash abbey sharp to save 10 off of your
first purchase of a website or domain
also very quickly you can check out my
disclaimer here on the screen
so feel free to pause the video to read
it or check it out in the description
below
and don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you
never miss out on a video all right
let's see what this guy eats and i don't
really eat
unless just like a morning time thing i
wake up and i have to go do something
but usually when i wake up on a daily
basis i don't really eat
okay so i mean that's not uncommon to
hear
so if he's not a breakfast person cool i
mean that isn't going to
make or break your health like we used
to think
now i am personally a big fan of
breakfast
but contrary to previous belief it's not
necessarily the
most important meal of the day so one
review of the literature suggested that
eating breakfast
wasn't a reliable way to lose weight and
skipping breakfast
did not put you at risk of gaining it so
i say eat when it works for you having
said that
starting your day off with a balanced
meal can often help mitigate
overeating later on in the day so if you
do want to become a breakfast person
when maybe you're just naturally not i
recommend starting with something
refreshing
and light like a smoothie or even
something like a granola bar and a piece
of fruit
and then working your way up to a more
substantial meal
as your appetite improves i just got
into chips i didn't i didn't eat chips
for a while like i didn't really care
for chips but chips are kind of cool
chips are kind of cool it's the coolest
the right kind of chips
it's these chips from japan but they
from they're from canada
but they sell them in japan name maple
chips
they taste like syrup so
i want to claim this ingenious concept
as truly canadian
because come on maple bacon
what other country would have this
classic
combination top of mind to infuse into
chips
but i did google this i googled it hard
like i was all the way on the 10th page
of google before i gave up
and sadly i cannot substantiate any of
such claims
in fact i couldn't even find evidence
that they even still
exist which is a travesty in itself i
would say
no doubt
but anyways if these chips do actually
exist if these are a real thing
in the universe let me know in the
comments below and also
pop a bag in the mail for me do a girl a
favor
i gotta try these let's see what else
it's these honey
hot cheese
puffs i sound like a fat kid they also
like
lay's honey i think they call honey
barbecue
cheeto puff popcorn i hate it too
but not the puff but like the puff
popcorn
slap whoa this guy's passion for crunchy
snacks
is commendable i mean i can feel the
emotion here and it is
it is hard to criticize a man with so
much passion
about anything now obviously i'm all for
chips and cheese puffs
and popcorn and all those things in
moderation even if you want to like
crush a bag
of that for breakfast you do you but of
course
i'm definitely hoping that we get to see
a little bit more protein
and some healthy fats and some fiber in
some of the meals and snacks
to come let's take a look i love uh
thin mint girl scott cookies i got about
40 boxes at the house
40. yeah this is amazing
uh i mean thank you for supporting the
girls of america
a lot of reef knots were probably tied
thanks to this man right here um but
again
like the chips nothing wrong with a
cookie or two a day in the context of a
healthy balanced diet
um but what i am disappointed about is
that he's
teen thin mints and not samoa
i'm a little taken aback by that i mean
leave me a comment below on what girl
guide cookie
you stockpile each year these are really
important questions we need answers to
i like cinnamon toast crunch cereal bars
but it's two different kinds
long con it says king size and then
there's a smaller kind but they're not
the same brand
oh man okay so i'm a little upset that i
did not know that these existed
because as a kid i was low-key
obsessed with cinnamon toast crunch
cereal
and i actually recently bought a box
because i saw it on my ubereats app when
i was
emergency buying some milk from a
convenience store and then i
tried it and honestly
it wasn't even that good honestly
seriously adulting can feel like such a
disappointment when stuff like that
happens
are you okay
but as for the bars there is only 100
calories in one of them so
totally not a big deal if you're craving
a little selling sweet and small
and nostalgic but there's no fiber
and only a gram of protein so it's not
really going to provide you with that
much satiety
if you're hoping to use it as a
replacement for an actual breakfast meal
in fact if you look at the ingredient
list we see sugar listed
six different times under different
names
sneaky little bugger so if you're
looking at a box of cereal or a snack
bar and you're trying to limit some of
the added sugar in your diet
you want to look for any syrups or words
that end
in oats so like fructose dextrose
maltose and sucrose and while i have no
issue with some added sugar
in cereal or bars the higher up on the
ingredient list
the more of that ingredient makes up as
a relative proportion
in the product so ideally we want to
look for ingredient lists where
sugar is the ingredient near to the
bottom
me and my security one time we drove
around for an hour looking for these
clementos crunch
cereal bars and i want them so bad i
wouldn't stop we just kept going
different guys
we kept going we kept going kept going
did we find them
no we didn't find them wow
dedication that is dedication i mean
thank goodness men can't get pregnant
because with these cravings
this man would be one high maintenance
pragers i'm having such a craving for
burgers it's like my body is just
craving red meat
and mint chip ice cream but only mint
chip any other ice cream makes me want
to puke
isn't that weird yes stewie that's the
one weird thing in all this
just saying i love sour gummy octopus
yes also this is candy from japan it's
like um
i choose it's like a hai with nerds in
it
oh wow yeah yeah he's he's still going
with the list so there's these smarties
squeeze candies you making me think
about all my snacks i like like if you
could take smarties and unravel them but
crush it up and make it squeeze candy oh
anyone else just like dying for a
vegetable at this point
like a carrot like like even like an
itty bitty baby carrot
would be nice well the man likes his
candy
i think we established that little
factoid because
we are like halfway through this video
and the only thing we've heard about is
his favorite
7-eleven finds definitely bringing back
some real good memories here folks but
you know hey if if this amount of sugar
feels good to him
cool it does sound like he's kind of
just wandering down memory lane with
this
listicle of 90s sweets so i'm assuming
or at least hoping that he doesn't
exclusively eat
all of these foods as a meal but
you know me i'm all about adding not
taking away
so if my man yadi was craving that
smarty squeeze candy for his morning
meal
then baby you squeeze that sugary goo
into your mouth
with gusto but maybe we can try to just
like
pair it with a couple eggs or some nut
butter on
toast i mean that little addition alone
would definitely help stabilize his
energy levels
improve satiety and result in a more
nutritionally
balanced meal what's next
so i like spongebob krabby patty gummies
too you know those like the gummies like
the cup patty gummies those go
crazy the gummy pizzas not like the
gummy pizzas but the gummy hot dogs
like the um it's like a hot dog but you
could tear it apart and it's gummy
okay i just gotta know is there a
legitimate difference in
flavor between a gummy pizza
and a gummy hot dog or is it just more
like fun to eat the long
mini foods versus the flat round mini
foods or does like the green
relish count as a serving of greens
so many questions yellow m m's that's
the classic
that's probably the first candy i can
remember yellow
who the heck wants the yellow ones this
sounds like one of those real
strange rider requests i don't know blue
was always the most sought after color
of anything in my household
yellow is definitely close to last there
oh
sleepy time i want to talk about this
stop this video right now
and rank your m ms from best
to worse i need
to know do you ever eat food i never ate
them no
no even if like someone makes you who
gonna make me do it i don't know like a
dolphin
you're crazy got it okay
this is starting to make sense first of
all
we're all grown adults and the cool
thing about being a grown-up
is that yeah no one can tell you what
you have to eat
or not eat so if yay doesn't want to eat
vegetables
he doesn't have to you know but let's
talk about the implications of eating
just like straight up candy
and no fruits or veg first of all
what would happen if you ate legit no
produce at all
well i remember when i was doing my
internship a woman came into the er
who had some psychological issues and
had developed an actual
phobia of eating fruits and veg
and as a result she was the first case
of scurvy
aka vitamin c deficiency that any of the
staff at the hospital had ever seen
now you maybe have heard of scurvy in
relation to sailors in the 1800s because
it was apparently hard to safely carry
fresh produce
on board but this is incredibly
rare in the first world today because
there's literally
bits of vitamin c in so many fruits and
veggies i mean you could just drink a
cup of orange juice to get your
fill stewie go easy on the orange juice
that stuff doesn't grow one
wait it does so no while i haven't seen
any fresh
produce in yadi's diet he does
like his potato chips and while maybe
not the most nutritious
source of antioxidants they are made of
potatoes
and they are rich in vitamin c so
i guess his enthusiasm about honey
barbecue and
maple bacon chips is serving him some
benefit
now the more likely immediate concerns
around a diet rich in candy and low in
fruits and vegetables would be
constipation from a lack of fiber
energy spikes and fatigue from the high
glycemic load
and skin aging and breakouts in fact
one study found that teens who consumed
more added sugar
had a 30 increased risk of developing
acne
and considering his public presence i do
assume that aesthetics
are consideration for him now the next
question i'm sure i'm going to see
in the comments section is whether or
not this way of eating will cause
diabetes
first of all there is a lot of
correlational research suggesting a
strong association between
sugar intake and type 2 diabetes even
after controlling for
total calorie intake body weight alcohol
consumption
and exercise if we look at this directly
this association might be explained by
the idea that
excessive fructose intake may increase
inflammation in the body fatty liver and
localized
insulin resistance but then the other
indirect argument is related to weight
and i want to take a quick second here
to unpack that
obviously eating a diet rich in free
sugars without any fiber to help
slow down its absorption is not going to
be
very satiating and may therefore be
really easy to overeat so then the
theory follows that consuming an excess
of calories
leads to weight gain and body fat does
make it harder for the
insulin to make its way into the cells
however
this is actually just one small part of
a very complicated puzzle
and in fact insulin resistance also
increases body fatness because of its
role as a growth hormone
also with regards to the sugar argument
starving insulin resistant cells
don't cry out for broccoli they call out
for straight-up sugar
in other words it's a two-way street
here so
it's really important not to put the
blame on the individual
and their lifestyle choices especially
since losing weight without addressing
some of the other causes of
insulin resistance like stress poor
sleep
saturated fat intake medications
poor pain management and physical
inactivity
may not fully fix the problem so people
with type 2 diabetes come in a wide
range of body sizes
and shapes many of whom eat a generally
balanced diet
so we really should not assume that
somebody is going to get diabetes
because they eat a lot of
junk food or that they're going to avoid
diabetes because they eat
clean diabetes is a huge complicated
topic so
this is just really scratching the
surface here but if you want
more details leave me a comment below
having said
all of that there is a reason why the
official guidelines recommend limiting
added
sugar to no more than 10 of your total
calories
as it is associated with a wide range of
chronic disease
so for example one study following 8 000
people for
22 years suggested that men who consumed
67 grams or more of sugar per day
were 23 more likely to develop
depression
than those who consumed 40 grams or less
there's also a lot of research linking
excessive sugar intake to
greater risk of cancer and heart disease
but alas
like pretty much all of the research
that i've cited here
this is all correlation not causation
there are a lot of confounders that it's
really hard to control for when we look
at sugar intake
and its complicated relationship with
disease for example
it's always very possible that
populations who have higher rates of
sugar intake
are also more economically disadvantaged
and face other barriers to good health
like inadequate health care
stress sleep lack of education etc
but alas i am very excited to hear a
little bit more about yachty's hit list
of sweets so let's get into it
i love exotic sodas like bubble gum soda
cotton candy soda
red cream soda candy dry they make sodas
that aren't
ginger ale like they make regular sodas
they have a vanilla cream soda
that was a moment of silence guys say
quick amen
to the soda gods to close off this ode
to exotic soda here
exotic soda exotic soda
that is a term i did not know i needed
in my vocabulary
but i will say i too love me a classic
pop shop cream soda sprite
tropical mix now tropical mix
my theory is it's a reincarnation
of sprite remix it's the best flavor
sprite of all time
well the spoiler brown mix was crazy too
but that was a long time ago
this guy has actual like scientific
theories on soda
like if they gave out doctorate degrees
in soda
this guy would be on his way to tenure
like he definitely knows so
um mystics yo mystics go
dumb and for anybody who hasn't had a
mystic you missing out on life
apparently my life has no meaning
anyone else feeling seen oh yeah that is
us to a tee
i don't drink tea tea sucks anybody who
drinks tea
is gonna grow old quick uh
not to sound like a crotchety old bitty
offended by the t hate
but so studies suggest that a diet rich
in antioxidants
like those found in black and green tea
may help improve
blood sugar and blood cholesterol levels
over
time and lower the risk of certain
cancers
and age-related degenerative diseases
there was also two longitudinal studies
on japanese adults
that showed those who drank the most
green tea were less
likely to die just saying but
boom any wing spot that has peace juice
probably has a low rating it's probably
dirty in the back
but it's good this is probably the
funniest line
so random in the whole interview note to
self
check wing restaurants for peach juice
on the menu
and weigh the risks and benefits of said
peach juice
with food poisoning got it
i used to really love root beer you know
why because me and my dad used to go to
cracker bread when i was a kid
and when we would go to cracker bread
they'd give you a root beer and it'd be
in a bottle and i would drink it like
it's a beer
and i act like i was drunk okay but like
really what kid
didn't pretend their root beer was the
real deal
like if you didn't feel slightly
rebellious drinking your root beer while
driving around the mall parking lot with
your learning permit
well your childhood is probably
a lot more pure than mine now as for
yachty's love of soda
again i have nothing against an
occasional root beer if that is what
brings you
joy however there is a lot of research
linking an excess in sugar sweetened
beverages
to chronic disease so one study found
that for each
daily serving of sweetened beverages
kids risk of obesity went up by
60 percent it's also been associated
with higher rates of non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease
type 2 diabetes metabolic syndrome heart
disease
and cancer not to mention the impact
on teeth i mean i'm not sure if that's
the reason for his
35 000 rainbow grills
but man seems like a big price to pay
for a literal sweet tooth and on that
note
yeah wow i learned a lot about candy and
chips and soda pop that i did not know i
needed to know
but i am feeling a lot more prepared for
my next movie night in
and for parenting two kids who will one
day become
teenage boys and probably eat me
at a house and home hey mom
the meatloaf but what can we say about
lil yachty's diet
well this video was called
everything lil yachty eats in a day so
normally
these episodes do walk us through like a
typical day of
meals but this one was kind of more like
a greatest hits list of nostalgic
sugary eats so i hope that's
what it was at least i mean i know he
said he didn't eat fruits and veg
but man i would have been thrilled to
know that there was like a chicken wing
thrown in there with the peach juice and
the yellow m m's
like something like anything which is
like a little bit of protein and fats to
help
slow down the absorption of all that
added sugar
now there's nothing wrong with a little
cookie or a bag of chips or even
a blue dyed cotton candy flavor pop in
the context of a balanced diet
but i cannot imagine that only eating
sugar
would feel very good i mean this kid is
23 so
maybe in a few years he will start to
notice like hey
you know eating cherry blasters and
cream soda for lunch
kind of makes it hard for me to take
maybe i should throw like a sandwich in
the mix or something
and that's really all that would need to
happen
so if we add in some healthy fats and
fiber and protein
into those meals and snacks it will not
only help to
temper the extreme energy fluctuations
but also would likely
edge out some of those higher sugar
snacks because
you would just feel more satiated and
full so
lil yachty my love i'm not going to tell
you
how you need to eat because like you
said nobody can tell grown man
to eat his vegetables not his doctor not
his dietitian
not even his mother but the kid is still
young so
i would expect over time he may start to
be able to
pick up on some cues about how food
affects
his body and he might just see some
shifts in his attitude towards broccoli
and berries
well that's the hope at least and on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and a big thank
you to squarespace for sponsoring
i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you